- Un parc denénénénénénénénénén.
Nous sommes à quelques
kilomè d d de l'endroit où
l'oeil de Ian a touché terre.
Frappée de plein fouet,
la phahahahahahahahahahahahahahu
aucune chance. Ses résidents
ntntnt un cauchemar.
- As-tu vu? Regarde.
- Ah! mon Dieu!
- Il y de l'eau là-dedans.
- La maison de Jea a a a a a a x
résisté, mais une partie du toit
s'est quand mênvnvnvolée.
Dr JEAN MURPHY, médecin de
famille, Port Charlotte, Floride
- Ça dépasse tout ce qu'on a pu
avoir vécu auparavant. Ça a duré
tellement longtemps, ça avançait
de 5-6 milles à l'heure.
C'est... c'était un supplice.
MARTHE PELLETIER,
conjointe de Jrphy
- Je suis très émotionnelle.
OK, ça va, ça vient.
On fait , , , , , , , , , , , ,.
Puis, on recommence. Puis quand
on vdededes situations qu'on...
c'est parce que juste...
on est disconnectés du monde,
on sait pas ce qui n n n n n n t
même pas que Fort Myers, pas
tellement loinététété dévasté.
Sans électricité, sans eau
courante, ils vont puiser
dans leur pi l l l l l l l l l .
mais presque. Et je peux pas
concevoir de continuer à vivre
de même pour la prochaine
semaine ou deux.
- Au moins, à Port Charlotte,
un semblant de vie normale
a re a a aujourd'hui.
Quelques épiceries ont rouvert
leurs portes et des dizaines
vavavavavavavavavavavavavavavav,
une des rares à avoirdedede l'e.
Les résidents en ont
des mois à s'en remettre,
mais on sent leur solidarité.
"La maison de mon voisin a pris
ututut d'un coup, dit Rodney
Taylor. Je suis venu ramasser
un peu avant qu'il revienne."
cette église, détruite.
Ce n'est pas le Christ tombé
que Rodney Taylor a remarqué
le plus, mais cette croix
d d d d d d d d d d d d d d d .
- That means a lot.ThThThat mea.
We all have hope, yeah.
- Cet espoir, aujourd'hui,
c'est ce à quoi s'accrochent
les résidents de Port Charlotte.
On est corrects. Et puis...onon,
comme tout le monde.
- Ici Jean Sébastien Cloutier,
Radio-Canada, Port Charlotte